hi there i'm rachel ray i got a
screenshot
a little while ago and um i have to do
online traffic school
this is the link that i was given after
i paid my fee
which was 416 dollars
i was going 85 and a 65. i'm clicking
now on
home study look at all these
so check some of these out all right uh
gotta ticket.com boring
here's aloha traffic school with a very
peanut looking pineapple
i don't like that um
happy traffic school don't worry be
happy
thank you
comedy school for less oh
that looks crappy i like it
forget gps and anti-lock brakes what the
world really needs is a windshield wiper
that won't hold parking
boy i think we found a winner
of course it's obvious you can't drink
while driving but
there's nothing in there that says you
can't drink while you're in traffic
school
to guarantee you read the entire course
we've positioned security jokes
throughout the test
to make sure that the actual violator
and not someone else's taking the course
i would never do that i would never do
that
[Music]
while we're bored here's a little tour
of my desk
uh little kleenex packs dental floss
hot sauce oh by the way here's a photo
of me and conan and latoya that my wife
found in a file
oh that hot sauce was hot um a
clothespin
i think you know why that's there
pre-signed headshots
oh wow this
whole process could take somewhere
around six hours
we're obviously not gonna show you all
of that so here just is a little
diversion
look at this
[Music]
okay that's it i'm ready to submit my
answers but there's one thing i want to
do before i
click submit answers
i clicked you've passed with a 92
whatever i'm done